hello guten tag mutation welcome welcome
to my surgery - further spits plastic
surgery for your body to make you look
very very nice very chic very sweg oh
but what is this first you have problems
with toenail no problem no problem no
problem
Oh God opens from the edge of the
toenail gross down and into the flesh of
the toe that happens are you okay let's
say inject so this happened to me once
but it did not I look at this shitty
alright very good
Oh got a little bleeding the problem the
problem you just relax it's going to be
fine I like to do a little jazz dance I
live 8 thanks with me you can dance it
ok I will now place this circle around
your table very good okay the sound
first carefully slide one blade of the
nail envel under the affected nail I am
surprised then this toe has just not
exploded from the pressure we're going
to go down the nail until we feel a
little bit of resistance our patients
going to feel yeah sure as we cut away
the ingrown nail you may feel I let the
better punch a do you feel this ok
how is it oh oh oh great take the
forceps and carefully remove the ingrown
nail I I bet you have a glide then we
put the anesthetic
alright I'm firmly squeezed the edge of
the toe to get as much of that infection
out as you can but what if I do not want
doctor Jeff oh god that's this is mine
oh my god when you're hurting the acid I
remove the tourniquet and we'll finish
up yes very nice
Hey good yes aren't you happy finished
by applying some antibiotic ointment on
a sterile gauze pad
why don't we who move the entire nail
that looks kind of sick it's the taupe
and wrap it in a gossip and äj--
all right it's done that's how we remove
an ingrown toenail you did a great job
today
thank you I stopped a document
[Music]
[Applause]
want some silicon Maestas very good we
shall begin now I'm cutting those
titties open can you slide your finger
into the incision and back and forth to
create the pocket for the implant I am
going to finger these businesses don't
tell Mattia very Oh God so deep jesus
[ __ ] ass this is a bad idea I don't
Oh very not good is this a vacuum
am i putting a vacuum in a TV oh god no
why would you vacuum titties ship this
hey it looks like the left implant is a
little higher than the right can you
lower it what I hope you like your new
titties yes yes I do i do really like
them
yeah you better like a broken up teenage
girl oh let me get my laser apparently
this laser can like put flames and [ __ ]
it's pretty hardcore oh my god it's
going you see a B PPP PPP PPP PPP
look how happy he is about this heavy
mover look he's so happy doctor yeah
nice you're glad I didn't give him a
penis I bet a pose I hope you enjoyed
this episode I hope you guys enjoy your
new titties you're less of hair
[Music]
and your top very good very good yeah
all right thank you for watching this
video and leaving like it is the least
you could do for this free surgery and I
will see you in the next video thank you
for watching bye let's keep blending
shed for the swim D 6
[Music]
Democrat
god damn immigrant